well good morning everyone
it seems a little bit I don't know
sacrilegious or something doesn't it be
sitting inside here on this glorious day
sunny day talking about the dark side of
the universe but it's going to be worth
it I'm absolutely sure
III often feel that one of the best
rejoinders to the suggestion you
sometimes hear that scientists like to
think they know everything and can
explain everything is the response that
came from the discovery in the late
1990s that the universe seems to be
expanding at an accelerating rate which
is was one of the key motivating factors
behind this idea of dark energy because
you know that discovery showed how
profoundly it seemed we missed something
about the makeup of the cosmos something
that now seems to tell us that around
70% of the energy in the observable
universe comes from this stuff called
dark energy and you know another twenty
twenty-five percent of it comes from
this other stuff called dark matter
which we don't have time to talk about
today just to make things clear dark
matter and dark energy are different
things if you weren't already clear
about that and we're talking about the
former and so what is or what is this
stuff this energy that seems to be there
apparently but that we hadn't previously
noticed so that's what we're here to
talk about and to do that we have
certainly two experts from different
perspectives on this subject eric
falinda
on my right is a professor of
theoretical physics at the university of
amsterdam Michael Duff on my first on my
left is also a theoretical physicist and
a string theorist from the from Imperial
College in London and as you've just
heard matmo Pablito has very generously
did agreed to sit in the the third chair
that otherwise would have been vacant
for this discussion and that's why I
guess you'll offer us very different
take an outsider's take all I suppose I
got the comic question right yes great
lovely that's always a good thing so
first of all I'll give you Eric villain
de to talk about his take on dark energy
yes I mean dark annecy is mysterious but
it's certainly there and I think it's
there for a reason
the universe is extremely large it's
also very dark I mean not totally dark
it's also not infinitely large and it's
also not infinitely empty indeed there's
something there I mean if we look at the
observed accelerated expansion of the
universe it's indicates that space is
filled with something and that's the
dark energy that we're discussing I will
explain the relationship between dark
energy and a and the expansion a little
later so I truly believe by the way it
exists it's not something that's not
there but it's not described in the
correct way our current theory which is
based on general relativity is namely
incomplete and that's my my main main
point I want to make in Einstein's
gravity we think about space-time
basically as having no properties it's
like a stage on which matter moves under
the influence of forces but I think
there are reasons both from the
observations as well from theory to
really challenge that point of view that
space-time is empty or made of nothing
first of all there is indeed the fact
that 95% of the energy budget is in this
mysterious forms which is either dark
matter or dark energies but also we have
insights from string theory from black
hole physics they tell us that space
time and gravity eventually will emerge
I mean it comes about from something
microscopic in which these quantities
phenomena I have no no real meaning so
dark energy and dark matter constitute
this 95% of the energy budget I mean the
stars that we see is less than 1% and if
we look at our current laws of physics
we only describe what's being observed
and what we observed are the stars and
maybe the radiation from the Big Bang
but that's only a very tiny fraction of
all the energy in our universe now in
physics we generally ignore what
is happening in the microscopic level
like the air in this room we don't
generally care about all the microscopic
molecules how they are moving we just
forget this and this is how we make our
laws of physics and also in our everyday
life we talk about things that move like
the cars and so on but not the air and
in there the same is true for space time
and our current theories are ignoring
most of the things that are moving in
our universe so I claim that dark energy
is actually the thing that we've not
described well enough and that there's a
microscopic theory that should
eventually explain what's happening in
in dark energy so I told you I would
going to talk about the relationship
between expansion and dark energy the
fact that the universe expands means
that things are moving away from us and
with higher velocities when we are
further away and eventually there will
be distance where things are moving away
with the speed of light and there's
nothing we can see beyond that and this
is what we call the horizon of our
universe though there's a finite
distance and you can think about it as a
giant dome around us where we can not
look beyond that's as a set called the
horizon and there are rises other
locations where the horizon seen in our
universe which have to do with black
holes and one of the big discoveries we
have made in physics is that horizons
have very special properties and this is
a discovery due to Stephen Hawking
horizon tells us namely about how much
for a black hole how much information
eventually went into the black hole it
also tells us something that there must
be a temperature associated with a black
hole and the same is true with our
universe the universe has a lot of
information in there which is the size
of our cosmological horizon and it's
that information eventually that we have
not been able to describe it we've been
ignoring it but it's contained in the
dark energy the dark energy tells us
actually that our our universe is not
just an T but it's being filled with
something that we still have to learn
how to
right so I think we're not there yet
with our fewest point of view we don't
know understand everything yet but I
think we live an exciting time where
we're going to change the way we think
about gravity about space-time and we're
going to change even the way that
Einstein well describes gravity with his
theory of course space-time by thinking
about indeed what is the microscopic
building blocks of the space-time itself
much for I'm I'm doing on time I may be
even during the discussion I can say a
little more but all right so my point of
view is that indeed we don't have to
find a theory yet and that when we have
it I think dark energy will be the most
exciting thing that's happening there
and there's lots of equations we haven't
discovered about it yet but it's
certainly an indication of the fact that
we don't have to complete to you yet
well in 1998 we discovered that the
universe was not only expanding but
accelerating and the simplest
explanation and the one I'll focus on
today is that it's due to the so called
cosmological constant that Einstein
introduced into his equations in 1917
now Einstein famously abandoned the
cosmological constant in 1929 calling it
the biggest blunder of his life and so
according to most popular accounts in
the intervening 60 years before the
discovery of the acceleration of the
universe according to these popular
accounts we all assumed the cosmological
constant was equal to zero now I would
like to contend that that is very
misleading you can find that explanation
by the way in the Wikipedia for example
and I even saw it in a recent edition of
physics world but it's misleading in
fact it's so misleading it's wrong for
example I myself co-authored a paper in
1979 entitled quantizing gravity with
the cosmological constant so we
certainly weren't assuming it was zero
and others had the same opinion in fact
I'll argue that the onus was on those
who thought it was zero to prove
otherwise not the other way around now
why do I say that
well the key theme and it's one that I
hope to develop is symmetry symmetry is
an idea that pervades all of theoretical
physics consider a snowflake with X
agonal symmetry if we rotate it by an
arbitrary angle it looks different but
if we rotate it by a special angle 60
degrees 120
it looks the same
[Music]
you